we've got another uh panel to bring you
now the first in fact of these uh two
days here at worcester park and we have
uh some newcomers on on stage here so
first of all i'd like to welcome dr
aurora julian from uel nice to see you
can you just give us a brief sort of
resume of what you do and
and the business you're in
okay so i work for the university of
east london
um i currently work on a project called
eastern new energy you might have seen
some of our ads
in the back
i'm a research manager for that project
my specialization is in building energy
efficiency
and low carbon buildings
thank you very much indeed we'll get
back to you in just a few moments doctor
um next up we have stephen fendley from
the east of england co-op just a quick
word from you stephen as by way of an
introduction please
just
forgive me
is this working
possibly not
should we move across to lewis while we
get that sorted out from cronus
technology lewis good to see you
thank you good morning
so i work for kronos technology and
we have a focus on smart buildings not
just smart buildings but smart
environments
we are
heavily data focused
pulling data sources from everything in
a building and we have
we have this interest in
existing buildings and existing data
everything on the network and the
stories that are being told between the
data sources and you can pull all of
these and put them in this nice holistic
view
um which gives you insights about your
energy usage the behavioral patterns of
staff and how that really affects your
business you know business-wise it's
sort of from customer experience to
going carbon neutral
and so we use these and you can set
parameters and reports and detailing to
really hone in on how you can control
your carbon impact so that's that's the
effective there's a lot to it um there's
so much more to it and it involves iot
as well and technology adoption so we
monitor all of this and you can tell
from the start to the finish where you
meet your goals how you progress along
as well
thank you very much indeed we've already
met nigel davies of course from
mountains just heard him on his feet and
also we heard earlier from shivali mata
from baze and also we have back of
course peter goody from the greater
southeast energy hub so welcome back to
the trio to the left of what i'm who i'm
talking to um how realistic then is net
zero this is an expression that
everyone's familiar with but
realistically
you know can we get there
we'll start with you dr perhaps
well i think um it depends
um we have the technology that's for
sure we've had the technology for a long
time i'm actually just repeating the
word from somebody called professor
jimsky
who
is at the ipcc and has been for a long
time
um
so so we have the technology the the
question is whether we're putting the
means into it
um so i think there's a short answer to
the question okay
and what about you stephen
no it's not on here sorry about that
it might it might work soon no
batteries flat probably
okay hopefully we'll get something
sorted there um in which case um lewis
you're coming to my rescue oh the
biggest part that we're here now steven
so net zero for for us we've as a
company we've committed to be carbon
neutral uh by 2030 with scopes one and
two by 2025.
the reason we've gone carbon neutral at
the moment is because we really don't
know what the net zero looks like so we
are going to have to employ some
offsetting as someone mentioned earlier
of saying
is it the bottom of our hierarchy rather
than at the top so we need to really
reduce
our emissions and
improve on efficiencies first
but yeah i think we can get there but it
will be a combination of reduction and
offsetting
okay lewis
i think that's a really strong point um
because it's a very difficult journey
some companies we work with you know
have managed to reach a net zero
but it's not through
just efficiencies alone
i think they play a huge part in
in getting there
in terms of you know looking at using
your own renewable energy um i think to
put that's entirely dependent on the
footprint of your environment as well um
but i think it
you know quite heavily relies on
renewable energy that you consume as
well
um just for us from the grid or solar or
um
wind power as well say if it's an
agricultural setting
but it is possible it is possible that
we know it's possible
it's making sure that
across a lot of different settings that
we can manage it there as well
nigel we've heard from you already
clearly mountains are well on top of
what's going on at the moment but of
course some businesses
will be burying their head in the sand
or certainly dragging their heels
yeah that's definitely true
is it on
sure that's all is it it's all nothing
okay yeah i think i think it's
interesting some businesses you know
they uh
i don't like offset offsetting so i'm
saying put put offsetting right to the
very last choice some business
developers have actually said if we
use offsetting as our first choice
we have to pay for those offsets that
develops a big financial penalty for the
business
therefore we've got to work really hard
because they're saying they think that
drives business leaders more than the
carbon i think that's very brave but
you're talking about companies that have
got
plenty of money and they use their csr
investment fund to buy the offsets so
they would have spent that money anyway
i think it's it's not a strategy that
most businesses could do just to spend
all that money on offsets particularly
when if you look even this year's gone
from 25 euros per ton to 60 plus euros
per tonne most businesses couldn't do it
but it's an interesting concept and just
an earlier question i put to um the
previous guests here how realistic is
net zero then in your view
i i think we've got a lot of uh
opportunities to get there i think it
just depends on your mindset so you can
you can get there if you just
get out of that pattern of thinking it's
somebody else's job to get there
or it's too difficult or we need new
technology all of those things are
incorrect starting points you can do a
lot yourself okay peter you spoke
passionately earlier um to the room here
and um presumably you think it's
realistic i could tell that you you
certainly believe in it but can we get
there
and it's a question of who's we
you know reductively individual
households businesses can take that step
and can achieve it whether it's through
on-site emissions reduction
or
where they can't achieve that emissions
reduction through other means and i take
your point about offsetting and i'm with
you on that one the question is around
fairness and justice you know this is
not a tech we've got the technical
solutions but how do we deal with this
as a societal issue not just in ipswich
or suffolk or uk globally and we have a
challenging environment
around fossil fuels we've seen
uh some of the lobbying that's going on
around cop26 which was ever thus
they were lobbying their interests with
regard to the current business model
around fossil fuels
um
we survived on that philosophy and it's
built a fantastic opportunity to get out
of
um what is a lifestyle that was probably
medieval pre-industrial so we need to
think around well we've got to build on
that opportunity okay
we've got a problem we need to address
but we've demonstrated that we can
address other issues of this global
nature um kobe pandemic is one we're
wrestling with at the moment
um we looked at the issue around ozone
depletion and cfcs is a challenge
but we need to make this a societal
issue and that's the big journey that we
have to go on so
yes we can solve it the question is do
we want to have we got the means and are
we prepared to take some of the new
routes that are available to us mr
valley surely
as you know a world issue now we've got
to solve it haven't we time is not on
our side
agreed but if i first go on personal
views on this a little bit if we revive
if we just rewind ourselves 15 years
back um in all honesty i used to spend
no more than 60 70 quid on my mobile
phone
i could never imagine spending a grand
on a phone
that was a reality and i would i
wouldn't even think that my life was the
phone um but it has changed
it's really changed overnight i would
say the whole ipod situation the iphone
situation the youth wanted it we want it
my parents want it it's every everybody
wants it and it's just not only fashion
it's comfort as well
we can see emails everywhere we can talk
and communicate to loved ones everywhere
so i think if we connect ourselves and i
think the youth is connecting that if we
do not change where we are now and where
we want to be
and it won't happen i mean it won't be a
better place to live so there is that
societal issue as you said peter and i
know that people are getting more and
more aware um why are people going
plant-based or vegan sort of a thing so
there is a drive from others side as
well because we
were unhealthy a few years back as well
but now it's no we know we can't kill so
many animals etc so from a personal
perspective i feel that yes
there is momentum there is
impetus as you said peter then we we can
reach the goal
um from base perspective and i reflect
back again on the net zero strategy
where we've talked a lot about buildback
better
it is about market mechanisms so we have
to enable the market mechanisms somehow
as government which we are working with
industry consumer behaviors
they need to change and evolve and we as
consumers need to evolve
um
and again investments so it's all in
together i think you think you mentioned
steven um and collaborative effort which
can make the change i mean certainly
businesses here in the uk have had so
much to cope with haven't they over the
past few years obviously brexit
the pandemic and now they're being asked
to do more you know for the environment
so can businesses cope with all that at
the moment
doctor
i'll come around to you again i mean i
do definitely think that um the fact
that businesses are being asked to do
more is a very positive point
um because the the sort of
it's always been about individual making
consumer choices as to you know whether
they would choose the greener product or
not
and and often this greener product would
come with a higher price tag
and this is i think a little bit of a
warped vision of how we can save carbon
i believe that we can save carbon
through changing how companies work
and certainly how they themselves can
you know become zero carbon will
definitely influence the products that
we purchase or that we use through our
own business activities so
this this sort of pressure on businesses
is certainly um what needs to be done
rather than just simply the consumers
consumers
have been demonstrated to not have that
much impact um even during the the sort
of first stages of the covet crisis we
were not saving so much carbons while we
weren't traveling as much when tanking
planes as much so the change was really
small but we do know that if companies
small and large companies make efforts
to save carbon then things are going to
change now whether they can um
i think
i think it's a difficult question
they certainly can have a go and we see
plenty um examples of companies that
successfully uh
reduce their carbon emissions very fast
and there is a little bit of time if we
really think about it 2050 is in a while
and stephen the story that the east of
england co-op obviously
in some ways have led the way certainly
that that's a perception i get but have
you seen more customers coming to you
because of your green stance very
definitely we're a cooperative so
sustainable
business and corporate responsibility
goes right back to the birth of the
co-ops and the approach to our pioneers
um
we're led by we're owned by our members
we're led by our members and they
expect
us to be taking action on our carbon
footprint and on environmental issues
get on um
we're getting many many requests now for
ev charges which we're rolling out
across this day
and
the the experts the amount of crews get
about plastic bags etcetera um
yeah
our customers have an expectation of us
which we we need to meet
okay lewis as far as you're concerned i
mean that that's a big plus point isn't
it for any any business to be seen to be
green and to be doing something about it
but some are going to struggle aren't
they to keep up with all this
i think so it's a it's very challenging
um
i think
if the past two years have taught us
anything it's that we handle challenges
by
um being diverse and flexible
and it it also leads to the fact that
progress is very slow it's almost too
slow
uh in terms of reducing carbon footprint
and
discovering how we can all make a change
um
i think as well um businesses at the
moment seem to be you know
companies that push the fact that they
are sustainable if they've got
sustainable products that are made from
recycled materials it's now a plus a
selling point and a plus point to be in
that scenario i think also for them to
do um
to take on new technologies and become
more sustainable
um
you've got
we like to focus on there being a
financial benefit to it as well and that
the fact that there is now money coming
out for companies um
to improve
the idea of saving money as well so it's
not just you know
we have to buy all this new technology
we can turn these lights off we can turn
some of them and i look at this from a
very individual level that's sort of
um that's that's where i focus on making
the change
um
and there is there is money to be saved
which i think will massively help and
that will encourage a lot of businesses
to
take a step in the right direction
okay we're coming to the end of the
morning session i think we could
possibly take one or two questions
if anybody would like to put something
to the panel get their views on
something that i haven't
broached gentlemen at the back there
we'll hand you a microphone in just a
moment and hopefully we can hear you
okay i'm sure we will be
uh hello hello i'm peter ellington from
triple bottom line accounting
my question is everybody's talking about
energy transition
what does the panel
think about social transition and what
needs to happen in society
and how
might that change happen
social transition who wants to
to give us their views on
how that's going to happen
it's a big question
they're all big questions
i'm reading a book by james plunkett
called end state
and that talks for example about one of
the transitions that needs to take place
is a ubi
so that people that have less money
actually do
have the ability to take make
consumption choices
because as people have said um
environmental choices are often more
expensive
generally they're getting cheaper but
there needs to be a whole new
adoption adaptation
to how we see money and finance
so that
poor members of the society in all of
society can participate in a new greener
economy
so
so really okay instead of a question
i pose that as a challenge
do you agree and
how do you
that society needs to change quite
fundamentally and how do you see that
change taking place
um there's two things that
what you're saying makes me think about
the first thing is
what i was saying earlier about
environmental choices and the fact that
when you choose as a consumer and green
product
it's inevitably gonna have a price tag
and it should not
and um so so this this kind of pets um a
sort of
you know it becomes the green choices
becomes almost a privilege of the who
the people who can um and so this is why
um
it's so important to have um
aims too big to have you know companies
becoming zero carbon in the long run and
i hope this is going to be um in place
strongly uh in the future there is
movement too in that direction but it's
very important but there's another
aspect of social behavior which
is really important which is brought by
not just the simple
choices of you know choosing this
washing machine or that washing machine
it's about
how we
use the things we use how we
you know beyond the rebound effect the
fact that for example when we
wash our clothes we wash your clothes
more and more more and more often
so whether we
wash them at 30 degrees or 40 degrees
doesn't matter anymore because simply we
should wash them almost every couple of
days
and these are very embedded within
society and practices of how we do
things um and these are the the things
that are the most difficult to change
really um
and so um it's very important also and
certainly in academia that there is an
understanding
of these behaviors and how to um you
know direct advertisement in a way which
is not going to change how people so how
people um
behave so for example there is there has
been loads of
advertisement quite a long time ago in
sort of the 50s the 60s the 70s around
the concept of white clothes that were
very clean and smelled really nice and
you could see all these people on
television you know smelling the
wonderful clothes that smelled great
because they came out the washing
machine that has changed how people
behave um and there needs to be a really
good understanding of how these things
happen so that whilst we do improve the
energy efficiency of the systems we use
we also understand how people will use
those systems and that's that's
important as well i think it's a long
answer
to your
question no it made perfect sense
i think
from an ecosystem perspective 2015 net
zero energy system and if we look from
here to there um sorry i didn't catch
your name
but it's data and transparency as well
education um how many of um
i'm super impressed by nigel's story of
carbon accounting um and if there is a
model that can be used simply it's quite
inspirational so sharing the positive
true inspiring stories um so i i worked
on a project in my previous life to
previous to base
and we changed from boilers to heat
pumps
and now and again the same question of
why my radiator is not burning hot
was a question i answered to 500 plus
consumers and i just felt that
the behavior was so and the behavior
changed the moment they understood how
the heat pump really works and this is a
few years back and that's why the
radiator is not getting that burning hot
and it doesn't need to as long as the
temperatures of the room fine
that changed their
attitude to looking at
the problem which they were looking at
before so i think it's
the more we can get transparent on the
data the more we can educate the system
make people aware share our stories that
will help the social behavior the
consumers to change i feel and we all do
like to hear
so i i'm thinking of an electric vehicle
just because three of my friends are
really happy about using it and i have
some stories that yes they've done this
way this is how i accessibility if i
want to buy a heat pump where do i go
how do i do it um who do i go if i have
to service it so i think that
information is key um in transition
okay stephen just briefly i think
the cooperatives have uh as a
cooperative we we have a responsibility
to help drive that change our
principles of shared equity and concern
for the community we need to
provide opportunity to our customers to
our communities with the provision of av
with good products and ethically sourced
products
and with education as well we're
uniquely placed within the heart of our
community communities to allow us to get
that message to where it needs to be and
drive society societal change
thank you very much indeed apologies
we'll have to leave it there because
we've approached the lunch break now and
i'm sure most of us if not all of us
would like a bite to eat but thank you
very much indeed for taking part in our
first panel discussion
thank you